I'm gonna try doing this with like three
devices so we're gonna see how it works
um
and you are here for the Appley titled
numb Focus Champion Circle presents how
to make friends and generate impact
through open source communities
uh my name is Lauren Olga in my day job
of principal data scientist at bonterra
thank you for saying
um I actually work primarily on our
political and non-profit fundraising
business lines and I'm also a frequent
numb focused supporter and frequent
volunteer and today I am addressing you
in my capacity as the inaugural chair of
the numb Focus Champion Circle which is
a volunteer-led numb Focus committee
focused on generating leads and
informing fundraising strategy
so like as an aside it just because like
I'm nervous so I want to share something
personal so like you've heard a couple
of times this is my third time cheering
hopefully maybe last we'll see
um but uh you know it the first time I
chaired was in 2018 and I was like five
months pregnant and then in 2019 I had
like uh an infant at home and so like
because this is the end of spooky season
because we had like Halloween's over and
election days in the past
um and and now we're like in the season
of gratitude like I'm just so thankful
to be here right now and and like not
just completely sleep deprived or like
unable to walk across the
um the conference floor so I want to
thank you all for choosing to uh to
enter in this session with um you know
based on kind of an ambitious title but
uh but also an ambiguous one right and
maybe just like a desire to help
strengthen the open source community
that we have so let's let's take this
journey together
so I'd like to talk to you today a
little bit about the work of building
open source communities and how that
work has changed and the ecosystem of
volunteer and paid efforts that make our
open source Community possible so I
think this is an important time to have
this kind of chat
um because we can go back to First
principles of like why are we here and
what do we hope to achieve uh you know
we've been on Hiatus for two for two
years from in-person events but as you
saw today when everyone raised their
hands during opening notes right that
said like you know most of the room were
brand newcomers right the community is
still continuing to grow during this
time
so I'm excited to see familiar faces
here but I'm even more excited to see
all the new folks and how much pent-up
energy there is for building Community
um
so this talk is is intended to be very
beginner friendly
um but I hope everyone in this room will
benefit and really when I want you to
take away from this talk is how you can
help the non-focus community uh why it's
so important to do so and for you also
to feel very confident in your
background knowledge of like how
everything fits together so that you can
be confident in your quest to make
friends and generate impact while
building a welcoming sustainable open
source community
so
what is um
what is numb Focus right a little bit of
background first uh so you heard him
this morning uh in the opening notes
that numb focus is this 501c3 non-profit
Global non-profit that's the sponsor of
Pi data NYC conference Meetup and all Pi
data events globally
so numb focus is the organization and Pi
data is the brand and we can kind of
there's nearly 100 projects in total
between the sponsored and affiliate
projects so here's just a scroll of them
um
padetta is the brand used for
educational Outreach programs of numb
focus and as an organization num focus
is the fiscal sponsor for your favorite
open source scientific Computing
projects in our Python and Julia such as
numpy sci-fi pandas Pi MC Jupiter the
Julia language are open sign many many
others right um their logos are
scrolling here there's also a wider
ecosystem projects that are not num
Focus sponsored but they're Affiliated
they're often smaller in size or scope
they may be newer but they're still part
of this community
um they're listed on numberfocus.org as
Affiliated projects so I hope you'll get
a chance during this conference to hear
from and interact with many of the folks
who contribute to and maintain both
sponsored and Affiliated projects here
at the conference
now
that just scrolled some more
something's a little wrong that's okay
I'll fix it later
um
now what does this mean the projects are
run independently of no focus and
non-focus neither maintains code bases
nor sets project road maps for future
development
but affiliate projects have some
marketing funding and Community benefits
from them Focus such as access to
publishing their news in the newsletter
the ability to apply for and receive
small grants
small grants right from num Focus the
small development grants and sponsored
projects have even more
um connection to num Focus right so
affiliate is kind of the entry
onboarding sponsored projects have full
benefits so they have Legal Financial
and governance support from num focus
and for sponsor projects numb Focus
provides the legal infrastructure
necessary to for example award and
receive grants or higher paid developers
and developer Advocates we even have a
developer Advocate on staff at num Focus
now so
um
sponsored projects also oh yeah
I will say the Julia Community is very
willing to engage criticism they jump on
every discussion of the language and so
I suspect when you want to have their
self I think that's that we should
really keep that secretary
how do you get out of uh yeah
I think they'll definitely um
foreign
colleague I'm Katrina
Leonard's contract management account
guidance accounting guidance uh
promoting diversity inclusion project
management right there's a lot of
benefits so
so that was all about numb Focus right
hopefully that level sets a little bit
let's talk about how Pi data fits into
this so the pi data conference series
exists as the main educational Outreach
of numb focus in support of its mission
to support open source scientific
computing
so despite the pie in the name the
modern Pi data event is intended to
provide a welcoming language agnostic
user Community for all non-focused
projects and unlike a larger trade show
trade show style software conference
right you may be familiar with some of
the bigger names paidata is is powerful
because it's horizontal by Design right
you're probably you've probably already
noticed like in The Vibes here but what
I mean by horizontal is that there isn't
a huge hierarchical gap between
presenter and attendee many of the
attendees are open source users
themselves or they uh they're volunteers
their contributors right maybe their
future contributors to open source right
so like our attendees come from the
community and the community presents
back
um whether this is an Academia or
industry so speakers are drawn largely
from the same group with similar roles
and job titles
and we encourage attendees to further
blur this line
through events like the birds of a
feather room where anyone can host a
session on the topic of their choosing
much like you know kind of like an
unconference or during lightning talks
which on the end of day two anyone can
sign up to give a five minute talk on
the topic of their choice and by
um well oh and by the way sorry I kinda
lost my note there so by the way sign up
for both of these things it's on the
fifth floor
um at the non-focus booth
but Pi data is also special because it's
one of the largest data conferences that
isn't run by a company right now right
it's it's by the community and for the
community
and
oh I did have some little things there
huh
good to know okay perfect
Pi data NYC in particular let's talk
about this so Pi data Pi data NYC Pi
data is NYC in particular along with
London and some of the other larger
events they double as fundraising events
um so both your conference ticket and
your conference and our conference
sponsors provide critical funding that
make numb focuses educational Mission
possible so all the things we talked
about before that cost money this is
part of the solution right this is part
of the sustainability aspect so for
example every conference sponsorship
here at Pi data NYC supports one or more
diversity Scholars which provides a free
three-day pass to attend this conference
to someone who would not otherwise be
able to attend and actually this year
through the generosity of our sponsors
the pi data NYC conference organizing
committee was able to award an amazing
39 scholarships and that it was a
hundred percent of what was requested
from the application form we only had 39
applicants this year
um even though it was pretty widely
advertised right through existing
channels like the pi data Twitter the
mailing list through the pref
professional and diversity focused
networks identified
um through the conference organizing
committee that people are part of so let
me say it again
through the generosity of our sponsors
this year we were able to meet 100 need
and that's amazing right
[Applause]
it's huge and the work that we put in as
organizers and volunteers has a direct
and tangible impact on the health of our
community right it also means that we're
in a really good position to continue to
grow we should be growing our pool of
possible applicants we should be
building relationships with colleges
boot camps diversity focused meetups
professional networks right like we can
do a lot more to keep growing because
we're in such a strong position
but the pi data Community is not just
NYC based or us-based it is of course
Global right I know you know I also fall
into this trap as being a New Yorker of
sorts that we are not the center of the
world but our community is global and so
the pi data Community
um is truly Global because scientific
Computing doesn't have Geographic
boundaries right so when covid-19 forced
the cancellation of all in-person events
in 2020 we wanted to do something
virtual in its place that was truly
Global
um Diego Torres who's actually in the
room and Jane Adams who were lead
organizers here in 2019 he didn't know
that I was going to call him out
um they were lead organizers here in
2019 and they had already started
planning Pi data NYC 2020 right and then
that all got canceled and they had to
Pivot very rapidly and
um
let me see here and so along with the
board of non-focus board of directors
James Powell along with the chair of Pi
data New Delhi second Burma and the
chair of Pi data Amsterdam Mathias
bronze uh they really took the lead in
reimagining what was even possible for
this community in terms of an online
event and the the all-virtual pi data a
truly Global Pi data uh is what came out
of this right so there were talks all
through the night uh Keynotes and social
events happening during prime time
during all major Global time zones it
was a massive audacious undertaking with
55 organizers from PI datas all across
the Globe coming together to prove this
model could and would work and we're
actually in the third year now right
like this this has been so successful
that it's continued
um is stats that I'm showing here are
from the num Focus impact report for
2021 it gives you a sense of scale for
the event right 215 talks or
presentations and over um over 2100
attendees so Pi data this year is
actually still in the future so you can
attend this year it will be held on
December 1st through 3rd of 2022 so it's
less than a month away
um it runs for approximately like 18 to
20 hours per day I don't think the
official schedule is online yet but it
runs for a good portion of the day
and like in 2021 there was live
programming from 6 30 a.m to 2 A.M UTC
so it covers all major world time zones
um
the the tickets are pay what you can
right and there's a suggested ticket
price based on your home region and
personally I I don't know I feel
fondness for pi data Global because I
remember waking up at 4 30 a.m one time
local time to co-host a pub quiz
um in a virtual platform called gather
if if you're familiar with that so that
was in 2020 and it's just kind of
exhilarating to be up at an unusual time
like that sit in your apartment alone
and trying not to wake up everyone else
and interacting with folks halfway
around the world so just a call out that
tickets and sponsorships are still
available
oh uh oh
one second
I hit the wrong things and this is all
gone not all gone so
okay we're back
oh wait there's more
[Laughter]
um Pi data is more than a conference
series
um I did all says meetups and meetups
have also experimented now they've had
had been forced to experiment with
um more virtual and hybrid offerings
even as many have started meeting in
person again so I think this is a net
benefit that we've had to Pivot but
um
but it is cool nonetheless so just to
give a sense of scale in 2021 there were
190 Pi data meetup groups in 66
countries and having
um over 180 000 members so that's that's
a lot of stickers right when it you got
to draw it back to that so these groups
are active on every continent except
Antarctica and in 2021 these groups held
over 450 events with nearly 15 000 RSVPs
so the pi data Community is far larger
than the conference series itself these
meetups are the Grassroots effort and
they're almost entirely volunteer-led
communities dedicated to making open
source science and data science more
accessible and inclusive so even in
cities where there isn't a large Pi data
conference there may be a vibrant Pi
data Meetup community
okay so what does it mean to start
getting involved in building community
in tech for me it means that six years
ago I started going to local meetups
here in New York Tech is an industry
benefits from a strong tradition of
amateur enthusiasts and hobby groups so
either sharing and hacking away on
Hardware or low-level software like
operating systems or more recently to
show off cool apps and walk through code
and design decisions that went into
building them no matter how long you've
been working in the tech industry
there's always something new to learn
some new cool toy to play with and I
think that's I think that helps make the
industry a lot more welcoming to
beginners and folks with alternative
backgrounds expertise in Tech obviously
still exists but even experts can find a
way to channel their beginner's Mind by
trying out whatever's the new hotness
local meetups might get together in
person or virtually for talk nights
where someone from the community talks
about a subject of Interest or
five-minute lightning talks there's a
lot of different formats right there's
book clubs where it's a technical book
is discussed or hack nights where you
either bring a project of your own
um or you work on it by yourself or you
pair program on it you can
um
you can do something like the Sprints
that we held yesterday right and a lot
of times you can still hear me like
using the verbal tick of knights right
these things don't even just have to
happen at night anymore a lot more
virtual events are happening during the
day because they don't they're remote
they don't have to happen after work
hours lunchtime sessions seem
particularly popular so if you're
completely new to the idea of a Tech
Community I suggest that you start by
engaging with your local Pi data Meetup
get on their mailing list maybe they
have a slack Channel or a Discord server
there is a Discord for pi data generally
you can see what um upcoming attends
excuse me you can see what upcoming
events you can attend everyone's
participation matters and speaking as
someone whose career has tracked with my
involvement in the Tech Community I
think you'll find that having a
professional Network like this is really
valuable
but let's pivot right that's a lot of
background information about kind of
community and organizing and why things
are so expensive but let's pivot why do
companies sponsor no Focus
so I know that's intentional thank you
why do companies sponsor numb Focus from
what I've seen there's really mainly two
in mainly two reasons I would say that
one is kind of mission alignment and
risk mitigation from the ecosystem and
the second one is really about hiring
marketing and branding so the two are
not mutually exclusive and one of my
goals is the chair of the num Focus
Champion Circle is to better understand
how we can transform one-time
sponsorships into more lasting
Partnerships
let's get started with talking about
these two things separately so let's
start with limited event based one-time
sponsorships
um because this can be an entry point
for onboarding a strategic partner but
it's also an important unrestricted
Revenue stream meaning that events
generate funds that go through the area
of most need and not are they're not
earmarked for any particular project
so
many times companies seek out limited
one-time sponsorships such as a
conference in order to meet software
engineers and data scientists
um or other kinds of scientists so
perhaps they want to do this to share
open roles and meet their hiring goals
perhaps this is to develop brand
recognition among software engineers and
data scientists maybe they have tools
that they want to sell services that
they'd like these people to use and in a
third case a person already acts as a
bridge between the company and num Focus
right such as the case where a company
wants to directly sponsor events that
their employees are engaged in helping
to organize
so there's a huge amount of flexibility
in how we structure sponsorships for
events and in many ways the only limit
is our own creativity right so some of
the more typical sponsorships include Pi
data conference booths branded social
events
um sponsored talks it could be a logo on
the pi data Global website a virtual
Booth it could be physical Goods like
lanyards and charging stations it could
be digital assets such as sponsor
interview videos
um like the ones that we produced and
tweeted out during pivot Global in 2020
um thank you screens that are ahead of
the professionally edited recorded
conference talks so one year
um actually the very first year that I
was involved in pi to Pi data New York
the startup I worked for then sponsored
a plenary lunch panel and they did it
you know largely as a show of support
for me as an employee right but they
also want to generate brand awareness
for the AI software that the company
made so these sponsorships can be highly
highly visible and they generate
approximately one-third of num focus's
annual restrict unrestricted Revenue so
they're important Revenue source
and in addition to the pi data
conference series num focused sponsor
projects can um excuse me num Focus
sponsored projects also host specialized
events so there's Pi data events but
there's also like Julia Khan packaging
con
um Jupiter con right a desk con it's a
desk distributed computing Summit so
there there's a number of different
events um scipy is now under that fold
right where it's now come under
um is going to be a numb focused event
going forward
okay so in the binary classification
that I proposed
um here's the other half of that so so
the first one was limited one-time
partnership sorry limited one-time
sponsorships and I'm going to talk to
you about like kind of a sponsor partner
this longer term sponsor partner has a
different motivation from a one-time or
an events driven sponsor
they're not simply like a one-time
sponsor but bigger right like but again
um sponsoring multiple events but this
could be a common misconception because
generally long-term sponsors are thanked
and promoted through visible event
sponsorship right so oftentimes they get
thanked at multiple events and it looks
like they're just sponsoring the event
but truly they have a long term
strategic partnership with numb Focus so
instead these sponsor partners are
rather strategic Partners generally at a
minimum align with numb focus's mission
to promote open practices and research
data scientific Computing many long-term
sponsors have also expressed that
there's a strategic business interest
for them that they have built their Tech
stacks on the Assumption of a healthy
and functioning ecosystem of Open Source
scientific Computing tools they give
back to open source not only because
it's like quote-unquote words right but
as a matter of good business sense so
they may create in-house open source
tools themselves they may employ open
source maintainers on their staff some
companies pay developers to work
part-time or full-time on nym Focus
projects and in this literal physical
space in particular we talked about
Microsoft sponsorship right uh we've
been fortunate to have continued support
from Microsoft to host pie data NYC
because you may not be aware that in
that although Pi data NYC has been
around since 2012. in the early days it
didn't have a regular venue which
resulted in 2016 the conference being
canceled entirely for lack of a venue
and it's only since Microsoft has
stepped in as a strategic partner that
we've had a guaranteed space that this
can this event has been able to continue
so
excuse me
I'd also like to highlight there are
Partnerships that are not strictly like
monetary they're not necessarily
sponsorship based one of the initiatives
of the Champion Circle committee has
that that we've been working on is to
help map the many ways in which num
Focus sponsored projects are used in the
wild
so
in some ways so right determining where
num focused projects are used in the
while is
is interesting because in some ways this
is a Fool's errand right if you ask any
data scientist on the street hey do you
use pandas do you scikit-learn numpy
right like if they work in Python most
people would be you know most people are
going to
see like if you it'd be hard to find
someone that says no to this everyone
uses these tools so they're pervasive
right
and if you ask what they use them for
it's equally challenging right like
their answer might be like I don't know
data exploration like maybe maybe some
models in production like literally
everything right these tools are
foundational right so determining like a
use case sometimes can be a little bit
tricky just by asking people what they
use the tools for nonetheless
when we can distill down the right kind
of nugget of information this kind of
general knowledge provided from The Tech
Community back to num focus is
incredibly valuable in understanding
what messaging can resonate with
companies and the types of problems they
solve so the folks who run them Focus
are experts in areas such as non-profit
leadership events marketing governance
they're not necessarily techies
themselves that's changing a little
um but they do have us right they have
their wider Community to be the bridge
between project fiscal
sponsorship and how the government how
the projects are going to be used by
science research and Industry so an
example of the kind of information that
would be useful at the level of
something would be at the level of
something like I work in ad Tech and we
depend on counterfactuals to understand
and apply findings from our a b tests
and we use bayesium methods
um so Pi MC is critical to our work
right that that kind of like format of
snippet of knowledge or you know you
could call it a mini use case would be
incredibly valuable if we had hundreds
of these mini use cases that we could
feed back to num Focus I think we'd be
in a better position to start having the
kinds of strategic conversations that we
need to have with companies that support
this ecosystem or that could support
this ecosystem so if this stirs
something in you you know go ahead and
jot down a note right now so you don't
forget
um oh my gosh all right good to know
five minutes
but I'd love to connect with you after
the talk
so you have like a Google form or
something or something
um no I don't but let's
I love that
okay we're gonna skip that one
a little bit about use cases
okay
so but it's also
almost as if
it's almost as if you can work the
problem backwards as well right like is
there anywhere that you've seen some
amazing scientific or technological
breakthrough that we can you know we can
collectively ask what role did numb
Focus projects play here right I can't I
can't actually take credit for this
um idea uh Juan Luis Cano Rodriguez and
I were were chatting about this
yesterday and I thought it was brilliant
that he said let's turn it on its head
right
um as technical peers we can still have
these conversations right reach out and
say like okay the the helicopter that
landed on Mars like numb Focus was on
board right like non-focus projects were
on board let's reach out to those teams
and find out how they use these things
right and have these kinds of
conversations
wasn't it in the first image of a black
hole too it was and that is on the
website
so the time to do this is now right
there's lingering economic uncertainty
and there's kind of a slow ramp up to
hosting and person events so strong
Partnerships are more important to ever
okay let's pivot again real fast because
I know we're almost out of time so you
might be saying to yourself this all
sounds cool I work at a company how do I
get my company involved in open source
all right so first of all there's a
prospect uh sponsor prospectus you can
review on the website
but the best way to get involved is or
to get your company involved is to get
involved yourself so
um so show up right like we need your
voice we we need you to to to be part of
this right lend your voice to and ideas
to the cool things we're building both
in commute community and code
but like just even more tangibly right
you can contribute to talks make
examples be visible in the community
read speak read as a a meaning like the
the pi data newsletter right like get
involved in the communications Channel
be visible
you can also volunteer for the Champion
Circle right like um we have three
working Community committees so I think
individual and give uh corporate giving
strategies should be fairly clear from
from the kinds of things that we talked
about here but also there's a technology
committee where we're trying to help the
development strategy become more data
driven Our Community Committee members
are there there are one-year terms and
the year is coming up so please feel
free to express your interest
and here it was kind of like a theory of
employee driven sponsorship right so
maybe you are here right in in building
your awareness today and that means that
you can move you know horizontally get
involved your time your talent your
treasure right open that pocketbook
that's okay right but more importantly
like become part of the community your
time and talent are really really
valuable
organizing is The Next Step Beyond that
right provide a platform for others to
get involved
now your company's journey is important
to understand too right what is their
pain point
maybe you can pivot them into a limited
sponsorship right do is there a need
internally for hiring marketing brand
awareness
is there a partner a strategic
partnership there that that's possible
let's put it again right just quickly
because I know we have I know we have
plenty of time so it'll be fine
um you could say like okay so like I um
I think this is great I thought that
it's a little basic because I'm already
like super involved
um but
how do I really like have this
conversation with my manager like like
how do I even get that started right I
want to be seen as someone that builds
um builds Bridges to outside uh networks
and I want to be seen as someone who is
able to
um
uh make those connections and solve the
pain points of my company because I'm
looking for that promotion I want
something in my pocket right so maybe
you want to talk to your manager you can
outline your involvement in them Focus
right this is where it's like really
starting with yourself and
um what how you want to build the
community that you want to see I think
it's really important in focusing that
towards
I'm sorry in centering that uh
discussion with your with your manager
and then connect it to your company's
pain points right is there a need for
hiring is there a need to sell but also
your risk exposure right do you depend
on the tools that exist in this
ecosystem
um does it make sense to
to look into starting to support uh
non-focus tools sustainability
but actually how okay right away here's
the kiosks pi to sponsorships are still
available for Global you got to let us
know by November 30th let Jim know right
here uh end of your giving is important
that's actively being worked on and
we're we're looking to build up the
speaking pipeline the sponsor Pipeline
and the calendar of events for NYC
paiete Pi data nyc's Meetup so these are
media asks that that you can put in
front of someone right away
and that's it I'm I'm hoped uh
this was the talk so I hope you enjoyed
it
um my name is Lauren Olga
and you can find me on any of the social
media that's there uh especially
Mastodon as of this week thank you very
much
I don't have the email
um for the community
there you go
so we have a few minutes for a question
oh wow okay perfect yeah
hi my name is Allison I um organized the
pilot of PDX um
one of the things that my members have
been asking for a lot of time their
early career or transition from another
career like you know what is it that
they need to get hired and what I've
been trying to recommend is start
contributing to open source the library
what I'm hoping to find is some
communities who are particularly welcome
to welcome you to live and maybe early
contributors might give them a little
bit of shepherding a hard time finding
that there's been a lot of there's been
a gap between
they want a lot more expertise they want
to get more out of the of the
contributors uh more than they want to
give to the contributors yeah for sure
because it it takes investment for sure
right
um in terms though it definitely returns
have you had a chance to speak with
um the woman on your right
so um Melissa is one of our Keynotes and
actually Katrina as well right like um
if you if you want to speak to some
projects that are that are particularly
uh beginner friendly but Melissa is one
of our Keynotes in the blue hair and um
representing numpy as well as a
Consortium of other sci-fi related
projects that are particularly I would
say they're particularly friendly to
beginners
um and in large part through the
generosity of a large Grant from Chan
Zuckerberg right that these kinds of
initiatives take resources to put behind
them right
um so discovering that need of like okay
like if we can invest in this
um we'll get the gains back but we knew
that initial investment you know that's
where sponsorship comes into play
Katrina going to add to this that our
fiscally sponsored projects we actually
go through a vetting process for each
one of the projects where the board
members actually go in and look for
things that's acted like this a lot of
our fiscal and sponsor projects have
getting started guides in there and they
tag issues that are good for beginners
and so I would definitely take a look at
that as well
um and uh we definitely give people
kudos for that or suggest people do that
as well so but there is a way for you to
get involved but like you said I always
tell people is documentation is the
fastest way to get everybody right so we
must surprise presentation and in
particular I'm just gonna keep on canvas
as I always do if anyone's looked at
Candy's doll and see what I'm talking
about and it's a really good way to get
started
my people always have a little bit of
imposter syndrome they're like how can I
possibly help and I just want somebody
to be like yes you will help oh yeah
they're fantastic and and Jeffrey back
is actually here okay if you can help us
I don't want to hijack the conversation
but yeah we are doing this for the four
projects so now by sci-fi math problems
so for pandas we have Noah come here she
is working as a contributor experiencing
me and I'm going to talk about this
tomorrow and you know but
um that's exactly what we're doing kind
of being hosts for the new computers and
any point of contact so that yeah she's
not here okay in person but uh we'll
definitely uh we can definitely chat
later and talk about this
amazing do we have time for more
questions
Okay one minute
you take 30 seconds I'll take 30 seconds
so the I guess
more of the outside here I feel like I
think of a numpy and it's dissolving
very much government funded
contourport unit so my my image of these
days is having lots of government
support so I'm curious to what extent is
there let's see that's great so I'm sort
of curious to like how should I
understand the organization of numpy or
Pi data and kind of numb Focus as a
whole because the impression is that
like five toss five bucks a month at it
I don't assume that it's like a useful
accommodation
and so I guess like to what extent is
the government look at other projects I
don't think there's any government
funding right I mean
maybe on some projects yeah
NASA so that's that's this year and you
just are starting to spend money on it
not nothing consistent there's been
there's been a couple of projects there
was some contract work unit 15 years ago
but for the most part it's all been
most of the put in the staff is just
Rogue people doing things
that go directly to the project that is
actually a line on their next budget and
then for the other ones you can see
what's going to formal development
grants with going through Administration
and what's going for all of these
different things
so when you do give money to them focus
it definitely you know it goes for those
legal fees for governance or you know
paying staff members you know all these
things like that so that definitely does
help me
okay thank you very much
[Applause]